si vous regardez sellette
elles ont des dimensions qui sont
vraiment extrêmement proches de celles
des autres tableaux et la graphie et la
même inattendu à la surgi d'une
collection privée
sept représentations de l'apôtre saint
simon prêté pour l'exposition velasquez
serait-elle une toile du maître de la
peinture espagnole la manière de peindre
aussi de brosser drapé de travailler la
lumière autour du visage et le créer un
finalement un rayon de lumière autour de
ce visage pour le faire dégager de
l'arrière-plan tout ça sont des éléments
assez proche de ce qui existe dans les
autres apôtres qui fait qu on a envie de
se poser la question avec vous dans
l'exposition est ce que l'on vient de
trouver une nouvelle pièce de
l'apostolat d'autres velasquez trois
représentations des apôtres seulement
sont authentifiés peintes de la main de
vélasquez le fameux saint thomas saint
paul et la tête d'apôtres des pièces
exceptionnelles exposé à orléans au
milieu de toiles contemporaines du
peintre on a nombreux artistes
contemporains de velazquez qui sont
montrés parce que bien sûr velasquez
s'est inspiré d'autres maîtres donc
appuyé cité des références des tableaux
qu'il a pu voir et on a vraiment des
prêts exceptionnels qui viennent
d'espagne d'italie d'angleterre et qui
viennent comme ça alimenter toute cette
exposition absolument unique avec
parfois des oeuvres qui n'ont jamais été
vus par le public puisqu'elles viennent
de collections privées et c'est une
chance exceptionnelle que d'avoir la
confiance de tous ses prêteurs pour
mettre en rapport toutes ces oeuvres et
créer cette enquête autour des apôtres
est elle ne fait que commencer pour le
saint simon que les spécialistes
découvre comme les visiteurs pour la
première fois c'est un très beau tableau
il a une grande force est un artiste
très sûr de lui qu'il a t-il éxécuté
la question maintenant c'est de savoir
quel est cet artiste et à quel moment et
tout ça est donc ça ça va prendre un peu
de temps les experts doivent se réunir à
l'automne pour confronter leurs opinions
sur ce tableau que velasquez pourrait
avoir pas à séville entre 15 199 et 723
[Musique]